from yomi but a good result for Magnus
he leads in the match he burnt a bunch
of the clock off the match timer but a a
nice start I think for all the fans in
game one of the 3 plus one and by the
way if you're new to this Channel right
now throw a sub it's September but also
keep following the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
because this is another quarterfinal
match and after this one ends we do have
MBL versus nihal sain so you will not
want to miss all of the action here but
back to this board Benjamin we see that
we had an alipin Sicilian Magnus going
back to one of my childhood favorite
openings yeah we see Magnus here with
the Pawns in the middle he has active
development maybe The Rook can move to
D1 he's spending a little bit of time
though Yan still playing quickly there
we have the move for Rook D1 so let's
see now how Yan is going to play like
maybe bishop D7 but it all looks a
little bit clumsy so I think Magnus can
be quite satisfied about the outcome of
the opening here we see the move Bish to
D7 what white can often do here is
combined moves like Bishop to D3 and
queen E4 to try to start some sort of
attack on the king side and he goes
Knight C3 so we are going to see a
transformation of Pawn structure but I
like what you're pointing out that the
bishop on D3 will stare at the black
king and if you play G6 to blunt that
Bishop you give up the H6 Square for the
second white Bishop this is starting to
look like the makings of an attack but
Benjamin we know if there is no attack
black is better because of the C3 and A2
isolated
pawns exactly all of these pawns can be
a little bit weak the pawn on A2 the
pawn on C3 also the pawn on E5 nice move
here by Magnus going H4 because
eventually you want to go Queen E4 black
has to go G6 and then you can follow up
quickly with the move H5 so he can also
play H5 here right away anticipating
that move G6 and look at the clocks
Magnus he's down nearly 40 seconds Jan
is playing this quickly where's the
Checkmate says Yan you're attacking with
your queen and your Bishop I've stopped
that diagonal if he doesn't take with
the H Pawn I'll be very surprised
but Yan is thinking
so can you even take with the
Fon I'd be shocked cuz if you play FX G6
you critically weaken the pawn on E6 but
he goes for it wow Robert this looks
like a serious mistake I'm wondering why
he went for this like what he was
worried about on the H file maybe he
thought that white would quickly get
some pieces over there and he's trying
to bring his Rook towards the black king
but this bishop on F7 is a big
Pawn Yeah Rook A5 this looks very
awkward for Yan Bish to B3 now Magnus
will always have pressure on the pawn on
E6 he can maybe move a knight to G5 at
some point this looks terrible for black
really terrible and the C3 Pawn is now
targeted it is a weakness but I think
that white can go with a rook lift Rook
E3 both defending the C3 pawn and when
you move your knight out the way I feel
like The Rook would have been able to
jump towards the king side but he goes
Rook D1 and it got a question mark still
looks good for white
though right so what happens if yon
takes on the one how are you going to
recapture you can take with the Rook but
then you hang the pawn on E5 you can
also take with the bishop but you would
like to keep that Bishop in an active
position but what is this move A5 by y I
don't I don't see the point because A4
is not even a
threat so this question should be asked
again Rook takes D1 Rook takes D1 Knight
takes E5 perhaps Magnus would just take
back and plant a rook on D7 at the end
of the line and say that he's got good
control but that doesn't look very
simple I think that black would have
chances there but Benjamin the bar is
all the way up in magnus's favor yeah
this looks great for Magnus and takes in
case Rook takes D1 you can also take
with the bishop take with the Rook Jan
goes Bishop to f8 but this will always
leave him with very weak dark squares
Magnus traits on d8 and I mean maybe
like Knight G5 now oh that's a Crusher
because now F7 is hanging directly you
can't take this bishop that looks free
on H6 cuz Queen takes F7 Queen takes H7
is a direct Checkmate and if you play a
move like Queen E7 to save your Bishop
Bishop takes f8 that's going to hurt oh
goodness you just have no space for your
pieces and E6 is loose Robert I think
this one is just over if you go Queen E7
Magnus just takes and after Queen takes
Bishop takes E6 you cannot take it
there's Queen f8 and Knight E6 and here
same thing Bishop f s 96 and the game is
over it's completely done an extra
exchange for Magnus he looks bored with
this one and Yan has had enough Magnus
wins he is now up by three points once
more